(zooming)
- Hello everybody,
I'm Greg Proops.
I'm going to show you
how to make a martini.
This recipe is by Luis
Buñuel, the great filmmaker
and this is how that starts.
First we get a shaker
and some ice here.
This is from the Comedy Central
ice machine located right...
If a cube hits the floor,
that's what children are for.
They are you
indentured servants.
Have one of them pick it up.
We'll start with a
little vermouth here.
As you can see, this is
At Midnight vermouth,
a very special brand.
We pour about, I don't know,
2, 3 ounces of vermouth
into the shaker and
then, like James Bond,
gently, gently, gently.
And then, oh no!
Are we pouring more
vodka into that?
Right on top of the vermouth?
No, we're not and this is
the trick that Buñuel knew.
That goes out. That way,
there's a scintilla,
a jaunt, an iota, a
reminiscence of vermouth
'cause you don't want the
vermouth to get in the way
of what the main event
is, which is this fine,
Peak 7 Vodka made by a
very good friend of ours,
here at the show.
My strength is enormous.
I'm just gonna rip the
cork out all by myself.
There we go. Mmm.
Now, they've given us
a shot glass to measure
out the shots of vodka
and what we do with that
is before we get going,
you're gonna wanna...
Mmm. That's good Peak 7.
You don't want to measure.
What you want to do
is do it by intuition.
A couple more cubes
of ice here and then,
♪ Lalalalalalalala
Okay, that ought to
be enough for me.
A little shake.
I like two olives, maybe three
and so, we'll start with two
and stick those right in there.
That goes in first,
maybe a... mmm.
Then, the main event.
(classical music)
Right on time. This will
win you into anyone's heart.
It's the perfect martini because
there's a hint of vermouth,
not that big splashy,
icky puddle of vermouth
that you want.
You want this to
be an elegant drunk
because after one,
you're gonna be like,
I'll have another one
and then after two,
you're gonna be like, I
want anyone inside me.
(slurps)
(groaning)
I can't put you down
'cause I love you.
Smashing.
That is how you make
Luis Buñuel's martini.
And I thank you.
(piano keys)